this is sheikh jarrah since israel
occupied east jerusalem in 1967
israeli settler organizations have been
trying to remove palestinians from their
homes
not just in this neighborhood but others
too the issue has been subject to
decades-long
court cases at the core are two main
issues
settlers claim jews own the properties
citing ottoman era records
and palestinians argue they were allowed
to remain in sheikh jarrah
through an agreement between jordan and
the united nations
lawyers for the jewish settlers claim
that because the land was occupied by
israel in 1967
previous agreements are null and void
lawyers for the palestinians counter
argue
that previous agreements must stand and
that the residents have protected status
palestinians cannot take israelis to
court for property taken over by the
state of israel
this checkpoint at the entrance of
sheikh jarrah is new installed in
mid-april
israelis can pass freely but
palestinians who don't live in the
neighborhood
cannot enter even with press credentials
we weren't allowed to pass
until the police officer was satisfied
we were meeting a resident
that resident is mohamed elkhart he's
used social media to highlight the
forced expulsions of palestinians
from this neighborhood which he
describes as ethnic cleansing
but now he feels after this latest round
of violence
where hamas cited shaykh gerard as one
of the reasons for the war
there is a moment for change i think it
says a lot about national unity this is
a moment we have not
seen in a very long time particularly
since the late 30s we have not seen
the palestinian people rise up as one
body from the river to the sea and i
think it says
it gives me a lot of hope let me show
you what it's like when a jewish settler
organization takes over a home in this
neighborhood
this belongs to the el curde family
now this is their home this also
used to belong to the elkhorn family up
until
2009 when a court awarded it
to a jewish settler organization and
they've been living here ever since
that's the distance that we're talking
about we're not talking about huge
spaces we're talking about
a home taken over part of a home taken
over
from a palestinian family
sami rashad is one of the lawyers for
the families facing forced expulsion
he says that the latest conflict has
focused international attention on the
neighborhood
this case reflects many of the of the
hard issues of the palestinian-israeli
conflict
there are there is a community of
palestinian refugees living there
the rights of refugees the right of
return
the the conflict over jerusalem is is
just
reflected in the case of sheikh that the
issue of
israeli settlement and the israeli
occupation and the israeli illegal
annexation of east jerusalem
is there so it's it's no wonder that
this case is in in the now
in the scope of international attention
after confrontations between settlers
and palestinians
took place in may the israeli attorney
general has gotten involved
that has put any further expulsions on
hold
until june 8th when the ag has to reveal
his position
this is seen by lawyers and palestinian
residents
as a victory and confirmation that it's
no longer a simple property dispute
but one that also has implications under
international law
imran khan al jazeera occupied east
jerusalem